one of my favorite aspects of the Reuben
report is the feedback that we're
getting from viewers literally all over
the world just last week I had viewers
from countries like Egypt Denmark Mexico
Spain and Australia reach out to me just
to name a few I'm truly humbled that so
many of you take the time to share your
feelings with me and although I don't
have time to respond to everyone I do
try to at least read the messages that
you're sending to me the most amazing
part of this is that the conversations
we're having on this show are
transcending race religion sexuality and
Nationality the fight for free speech
the importance of not giving in to the
authoritarians and the awakening against
the regressives are all ideas that bring
us together the power of ideas is
universal when we discuss free speech
free thought and free expression it's
vital that we mean it equally for
everyone not just in an identity
politics based pecking order this device
this thing that we all have in our
pocket is bringing us closer together in
ways that we're literally unimaginable
only a generation ago right this very
second one of you is watching this
direct message while on the subway in
New York City one of you is listening to
the podcast while at the gym in London
and one of you is streaming this while
on your couch in Moscow not only are you
all tuning in on a variety of platforms
but you're furthering the discussion of
these ideas on Facebook and Twitter or
just by talking with your friends and
family that expansion of our
conversations makes me want to do better
work even if talking about difficult
topics comes at both a personal and
professional cost as the world has
gotten smaller it has never been more
important to hear voices the challenge
our thinking and give unique perspective
based on their own personal story my
guest this week is inna shevchenko inna
is the leader of the women's movement
femen international a columnist for the
International Business Times and a free
speech activist she was born in Ukraine
the same year that the USSR fell has
been kidnapped by the Belarus KGB and in
2013 was granted political asylum in
France she has lived a truly
controversial life and paid the price
for being outspoken more than once this
is not some
who only talks about the news this is
someone who actually lives it there are
many issues I want to discuss with ena
from women's rights and free speech to
Islamism and political correctness but I
also want to talk to her about life in
France right now has it changed since
the Paris terror attacks what's the
political climate has the regressive
mentality steeped into the mainstream
thus weakening free speech and helping
the authoritarians the only way we can
find answers to questions like these is
to be connected with people who aren't
afraid to share their views you know
there's a catch 22 to all this
connectivity as it brings us closer and
transcends cultures and borders it can
also make everyone else's problems seem
like our own on one hand we can see how
others live and have empathy for our
fellow man on the other hand sometimes
it's hard to gauge just how much
something across the globe should affect
us in our day-to-day lives I try to do
this show each week in the spirit of
finding balance between those two
concepts and I hope you know we'll
provide perspective on some of the big
questions I've mentioned here the more
we focus on our common humanity the less
chance we'll be able to be ripped apart